the pride of Norwich University and
Mount Union College yes is here in the
house here on the Rich Eisen show better
known also right now San Francisco 49ers
wide receiver Pierre Garcon good to see
you sir
Landy how does one wind up playing
college ball at Norwich University in in
Vermont that happened for you um I
remember like it was yesterday I went to
a recruiting fair you know
down the South Florida at my high school
and uh coach es coach ESL only from
Norwich University came up and said hey
we want you to come on a visit to her
mind hmm
and I was like all right cool who not
aware it's ABS never seen snow before in
my life no kidding yeah I got up to
Florida really know the ocean sure but
uh he came up to me he was interested in
me and didn't have to me to college to
choose from and they're like hey come up
on a visit and I was like all right cool
and so you went there when on a visit it
actually started snowing on the visit
but we were just decided to be in
Vermont be out of the stage just to be
you know on the college campus we didn't
know where we're getting us everything
we know it except which is happy just
you know young - kids just say hey we
went on a college tour and you know I
fell in love with it one of my friends
actually did he came on a visit with me
playing the same high school team but he
didn't go to Norwich University they
wanted both of us but I ended up going
in you know we you know that spent
alliums up it that's how you went you
saw snowfall for the first time I mean I
still want to go yeah CSI I was in break
into that bad boy free of it what why
why were you not recruited by any
schools in the state of Florida best you
can tell um academics okay guys one of
the main reasons I asked you didn't know
that you have to do well in school I
didn't know you have to do well on the
SAT and a CTA it's just I just didn't
have an older brother or you know
mentored like hey you should start off
in SAT or should get hired in a two
point or not just get a 2.0 get I it
into born so your grades can level out
with your SAT scores I just didn't know
that so it's an academic situation no
not it was just so not like if I didn't
know I like I just tried as I oh you got
to go to for another playing high school
haiku I'll just try to get 2.0 I didn't
know like might try to get a 3.0 for
sure no higher that it'd be easy to get
to a Division one school and once I
figured out I had to do good in school
yeah said I put my mind to doing what at
school and actually did better in
college than I did in high school
because like hey you need to do well in
college you're sure to play sports all
right cool and then how did you wound up
at Mount Union how did that happen I
actually had a friend that went to Mel
unity was telling me about my year and
at some point I got tired of her one bit
I was like uh let me try out Malian
because there if I went up in Division I
had to sit out a year but if I go across
I can either play and you know play the
senior in keep moving forward in my year
was the best decision I actually sent
coach Larry characters VHS tape of me
from Norwich University and I actually
put in the Postal Service not FedEx or
UPS the regular personnel now yeah a
regular poster and they actually showed
it to me when I showed up on campus good
the VHS with an athletic table on top of
it with you know my name and number on
it so they uh they were interested I
sent them an email and you know my age
so I got to get I got to do is up there
like be safe work and get you qualified
in financially and all that stuff and
then I mean you balled out you
absolutely balled out you were the
three-time all OH - s-- team member you
got on some radar screens Pierre Garcon
and then you wound up with a combine
which is a you know an achievement in
itself and how did you get there did you
have to send us resumes did somebody
knock on your door and say you're coming
to Indianapolis
I actually we're a pretty good team in
college right my junior year one of the
scouts so the ramps came - just running
for you made us run 40s a couple seniors
it was about Gordon to see a mask but I
guess that was the start of it I guess
winning games and college stuff let's
get on the radars and help me get on the
radar so NFL but uh I guess it's just
consistent years of winning and playing
world but uh I think I did well at the
Austar game but I think I got to come by
invite before was an all-star game to
the Texas versus the nation all-star
game a long time ago
but uh I remember when I got my NFL
Combine invite and it was a male that
came to the house and saying hey you've
been invited to the Scouting Combine in
Indianapolis IN boom yeah you're in the
RCA Dome and then you closed it because
the RCA Dome closed after your combine
and then you open up Lucas Oil Stadium
you went from Mount Union to going in a
huddle and there's Peyton Manning yes
what was that like oh yeah it was a
overwhelming it was a it was reality
it's like oh like this is this this is
what they really do is this is Peyton
this is Reggie this is Marvin this is
God knows whose doubts Clark just static
all these guys you feel commercials in
on TV you know it's like oh like do you
guys are real like they are real people
and they are really just good and
there's a lot going on right now and I
need to you know try to figure out as
much as I can in this short period of
time but my job was to help out with
such team when I first when I first got
sure I knew that and I I remember you
know when we're doing the highlights of
Colts games on NFL Network medion &
mooch we were having fun with your name
or Cara Garcon or or we would call you
Peter waiter is what we called you
during a during the highlights and then
suddenly Peter waiter if you will
started bawling out in in your own
respect what was that like walking into
such a professional atmosphere like that
and needing to showcase your skills in a
way to get on the field and then be such
a contributor to those Colts teams I
walked into the perfect situation where
I was it forced to play right away I had
amazingly friendly from Marvin Reggie
gonzo Dallas Clark those guys that I
could ask questions and they were
willing to help me it's paid into as
well like they told you exactly what you
need to do and Clyde Christian he was
always on me even to this day he's still
everybody they they put me in the right
position to do all I had to do was just
listen and do what they told me to do it
like it they didn't make it complicated
in making me try to figure it out they
were willing to help me in everything
that I needed so I was put in the right
position and once I kind of understood
it I can play that much faster because I
didn't have to overthink or wonder if I
was doing the right thing it was it was
known and I played faster than I think
I've made it comfortable neither
actually just naturally football yeah
and did he did never get on you do you
remember
you know there weren't a time where they
didn't get honest I was it could be
walkthrough it can be in the games it
could be anytime like hey did you get
the signal 8 you gotta listen to it cuz
you gotta be alert for all the audibles
and things that were doing that line of
scrimmage in it was it was a lot but he
was testing us and see how much we can
take because in the game it's life so it
was gentleman come so how much of his
ice cream Omaha fever which was garbage
how much was it it's it's all true in
theory says hey don't pay attention to
it and then that's when you know the
garbage start so it's like I the teams
that we played twice a year they try to
catch on today so they I disregard the
audibles and then we're gonna do the
play that we call but it was all real
into until he would say one word and
then yeah it was on me or not honest it
was honoraria it not live like disregard
look it didn't call to play maybe in
t'lie today Omaha Omaha Reno Reno Tyson
Tyson and it was like tonight we just go
run the play ears all those words meant
nothing nothing but fantastic but if he
did say disregard audible it was all
lies
did you ever be in the huddle and missed
the whole concept of this you know
disregard the audible and you thought
the audible was on or something yeah you
sometimes you do miss it because maybe
you're you're running back to the other
late or you're talking to another
receiver like hey you're playing it
where there's 80,000 people screaming
their heads off yes so so there's some
times where you can miss the disregard
Ottawa but he he was a good communicator
they walk you to engage because he kinda
has to fill out a game it kind of tells
you eight he's going to pick up on them
you just don't get a jump on it so be
ready because we're gonna you know gonna
something that's a little more yeah he
was good at letting us know what's gonna
happen before he does okay
a Pierre Garcon is here in the Rich
Eisen show studio I'd like to take a 60
second break and talk about what
happened in Washington and how you got
yourself to San Francisco okay and then
now your coach said something about you
earlier in the show when we come back
we'll play with Kyle Shannon and gave a
message for you okay and have you ever
seen a man drink a 40 ounce in one fell
swoop if you're having that okay you're
about to it's all still to come here on
the Richardson show with Pierre Garcon
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show with
the world and business in particular
it's become a pretty unpredictable place
these days but with wheels up your
aviation solution is just the opposite
they're going to give you guaranteed
access to a fleet of over 70 aircraft
with as little as 24 hours notice wheels
up is going to help you optimize your
travel budget without sacrificing value
reliability or comfort you can count on
wheels up for dependable unmatched
flexibility and total peace of mind it's
time to up the way you fly with wheels
up the most intelligent private aviation
solution find out more at wheels up calm
or call eight five five fly 8760 that's
855 fly 8760 I'm sorry that's not 88 .
the car cylinder but it's 8760 as wheels
up here garçon here in the Rich Eisen
show studios so you show up at an
interesting time in Washington DC in
2012 yes they go ahead and trade all the
way up for our g3 and then go ahead and
still acquire Kirk Cousins in the same
draft and you stroll in yes mike shanin
dare call Shannon's there and boom a
playoff season yes unfolds what was that
like
it was an amazing time in DC yeah we're
excited you know we had Robert you know
he was playing well Alfred Morris was
playing very well the team was you know
we were rolling we were really hitting
on all cylinders you know it didn't in
how we want it but it was a inspiration
because you know our future was going to
be bright because you know this was our
first year together and you know we've
accomplished you know going to the
playoffs in our first year so we know
that then we can keep growing and have a
lot of potential we have well rg3 you
know hurting his knee in that game do
you think he came back too soon next
year it was tough you know it was hard
too I was I was in the locker and so I
know it's hard to keep him off the air
because you know you worry about his
future you know we had the Jimmy shirts
and everything to them you know you know
as a young guy I always want to get back
out there but it's hard too for you know
the team of like hey no man don't come
out because don't play because we don't
want you to make it worse but you know
the guys like I'm good I'm good I want
to play I want to be out there with you
guys like all right you know we don't
you know we don't want to make it worse
but if you say you're good you know we
gotta we gotta let you play it alone let
the starting quarterback you know the
guy that got us here not play because
you know we still think he's there but
he's saying he's good
got a little play yeah and then he was
it just really clearly wasn't ready and
then the thing that's really strange is
he never got back to that first year
it's tough because you have to keep
growing and keep developing you know
once you know and then after the first
year they come out you know you're
surprised everybody did people start to
catch on because they watch more film
and kind of see what you do so you have
to keep developing keep growing keep
being a good football player in
different ways instead of you know no
team is gonna let you keep beating them
the same way every time
well so you have to keep getting better
at different ways so white and why do
you think he didn't improve uh I hear
the injuries did help it and that's
always self-conscious sub-conscience in
here that's equipment you're sitting
back in here you you don't want to look
at the rush getting coming at you but
it's kind of hard to not look at what
knowing your needs you know you've been
injured before and your guys are are
trying to hit you hard now because they
say you did you injury prone mm-hmm so
you know that plays in back in mine and
anthill
you can't run as fast or you can't you
know run around guys like you used to
when you first came in it's a lot of
thing that goes into it when you're just
paying too much instead of just sitting
in the pocket and either making those
but they started looking at the rush
looking at today I'm thrilled to see you
even that you start to you know worry
about things that you know you should be
comfortable and if I should be feel
stable but you know it he's always been
a runner he's always been naturally a
deep throw in a run he's never really
sat in the pocket to just you know well
what is that like running around and
running it perfectly because your
perfectionist and and then suddenly
you're at the top of your route and
you're ready to be hit right between the
eight and suddenly you're seeing the
plays broken down instead of it being
run on time what is that like that or
perspective it's like a we had our
scrambling drills where Robert starts
right we we have are depending on the
side I feel that you're on or where
you're at you have a location to go to
to get in the quarterbacks vision that
was what we always call it so it's it's
it's harder for four receivers to kind
of always some be ready for the ball
that's coming because at any moment you
can brake take off a red but it's harder
to play football but you know if you
practicing
got it that emergency plan if it comes
out that it's Kirk Cousins a franchise
quarterback a good Cormack it's a very
good French on Corbin he's the future of
the league you get some players around
him you know he's definitely he's got
some players around Natalie indeed a
true well he had you and DeSean Jackson
are you surprised that you guys were let
go not surprised you know the league
always trying a younger and younger and
younger you know they all and coach
Gruden you know it's a good guy they
always want the bigger body the bigger
players that have naturally advantage
over you know normal guys in it so the
NFL is growing to a bigger bigger game
where the DBS are getting bigger and
longer the receivers are getting bigger
and longer and they just want those
natura advantage and they want to get
younger so that's what this decision
that they made in DC which you know they
have every right to make it but Kirk is
going to be is going to do well for them
with Jordan Reed Crowder prior and quick
and those guys are he's got some weapons
to to continue this path that he's been
on for you know the past three four
years so why do you think again this is
no longer your house but it used to be
Pierre Garcon here why do you think the
team has not paid him long-term um I
guess you just have to keep proving it
like Kurt say every year is a contract
year for any player you know mountain no
matter if you sign you know five years
you can get released any moment you know
thing is guaranteed is you're guaranteed
so and I actually think Kirk is uh you
know being very beneficial right now
because you know every year you get paid
twenty million twenty twenty two million
well I know I know it doesn't hurt him
it doesn't hurt the bottom line but it's
just you know that the team could have
had a little bit more kept friendly deal
or less money that that's coming out and
and and instead they're doing it on a
year-to-year thing it's kind of just
strange it is you know I guess you know
they have to fall in love with them at
some point later I don't like I don't
know why they have it but you know he's
played well he showed he's played well
for the past three or four years that
you know I've been around in and
everybody else loves care all right Kyle
Shanahan the coach you're now your note
coach former offensive coordinator now
in San Francisco had this to say when I
brought your name up earlier on the show
cares
doing a hell of a job for us to tell
them that I was just keep stretching
them Creepo on us you just need to keep
stretching these two he's getting too
swollen huh
okay I like it enough but I just you can
never get to school but I like to just
have some home floor okay
I can't like that she says you're
getting too slow and you're lifting I
enjoy okay no being prepared to get hit
or hitting the defense when I can so I
got a listen way to prolong my career in
last 16 games or how much more long it
takes to to keep playing in this
physical physical sport and what's the
well I mean you're going to start OTAs
monday monday and you were in for the
offseason workout do around me what's
the mood around they're very I'll get
everybody excited everybody decided to
even get last season behind them to
start working towards something to start
working for the you know season to you
know to start actually playing games and
you'll see how we stack them in is to
have something to work towards you know
every week is a different team a new
opponent to you know grade yourself in
chemo for after after why it's out of a
you know lifting weights with the
stripping conditioning ahead right and
tell me about your your charitable works
with Haiti and what you're doing is oh
yeah mom's fair times now lately I've
been um donating a lot of stuff for
academics you know I've been helping out
giving out scholarships back in on West
Palm Beach Florida and Malian college to
as well to just uh help people because I
didn't go I didn't get scholarships help
people that need either that's our doing
world to get us to actually go to school
because and some people just need to be
put on the right path a lot of things
are not built around you know balancing
financing academic some people just need
a helping hand baby your cell there
should be yes but it's not fair so
something because some people have a lot
of academics but they just don't have
the financial support some people have a
lot of fan support II just don't care so
I try to help other people actually do
well in school from my high school and
put them in the right you know right
path to zucchinis continue do all their
life you know going schooling into
education is a very important in do
you should get reward for having good
grades in mean that's what of course it
look at you you're giving back to
the community and your you know this is
second time we've met many of you do
back in the podcast attending NFL Media
Group years ago and you just seems like
such a nice outgoings smart giving guy
and why do I hear you're one of the
worst trash talkers in the National
Football
I wouldn't say worst trash you're the
best because I have two it's a yesterday
you have to get yourself going it's it's
not that I the trash talk is not taking
personally but it has to like it when
I'm not throwing the field I have a
standard to uphold for my teammates
players my Division three buddies
because if you go soft where you let
something happen to you I throw the
field
everybody's gonna remind you of it but
if you go hard your teammates are
respected everybody's gonna be like that
because he's going Harding around what
it is here even if it's a blocking place
he's appreciating the game he's playing
our because you know he just had to be
I've been so what is an example of your
trash talk can you know I can go from
zero to 100 a it's an extreme it doesn't
go off the field okay but it's it's
extreme it's it's so what's on the field
like I can beat you look like you it's a
lot of four-letter words that my gosh
okay
are you working blue blue it's not safe
for work it but it's safe for your line
of work it's yeah it's a it's a locker
room I've never been Mike miked up here
and does that try the way I know I do
not want to get miked up I've ever yeah
I do it's actually I was like I can't I
can't put that out there because I do
not want to go back and watch or listen
or I always decline to get Mike done but
because personal lives are out of bounds
that's your unwritten rule yeah first
like we don't mind it doesn't go off the
field it but if you know some guys don't
okay know when to cut it off but you
know it I don't take it off the field on
the field you know we're we're working
at something but off the field it's a
congratulations you got okay so you did
well you can leave it there I can leave
it on the field I can leave them up here
look man I know you're heading up the up
to 405 say hi to everyone at the NFL
Network for me enjoy your day on the NFL
Network thank you for being here we're
going to use
have Chris law I mean if you want stick
around for just more of a couple more
minutes you can modify the for time for
that and the Helping Hands foundation
good on you sir they're on the NPR sorry
okay we're back with the the famed forty
attempt we're going to send you into the
weekend
yes properly here on the Rich Eisen show
that's next welcome back to the Rich
Eisen show want to thank today's guests
Kyle Shannon 49ers head coach you said
my current guest still sitting here
Pierre Garcon is getting too slow Hank
Goldberg said what do we what are we
doing on the UH we're doing on the
Preakness to eight
boppy at the four five nine right to a
exact with the four five and nine and
then on Monday show we're excited in
studio will be William Shatner are you a
Trekkie Pierre Garcon your Star Trek on
we got to get you into that William
Shatner will be here in person on Monday
show almost Abbott eyes we will talk
about tonight's games Bowl talk about
games two and three of the Eastern
Conference Finals and then Saturday
nights tomorrow night's Game three
between the Spurs and the Warriors and
we're assuming that uh is it three Oh
both when we come back out it will not
be I think your Celtics win tonight how
about I told you I thought Game two was
that spot and I think the Spurs win Game
three hope you're right as well I think
both about that I'll tell you right now
both series will have some blood drawn
how about them apples
I hope you're a hundred we'll talk about
that on Monday okay arm and that's let's
get the poll question all wrapped up
before we end our show today
Brockman yeah we're a big flourish big
forty floor and we're asking from this
point on who's going to have the better
NFL career with a you Pierre Garcon
Colin Kaepernick a Robert Griffin the
third who's gonna have a better one from
urano
expect that line yes 73% Colin
Kaepernick 73%
I agree with that are you now let me ask
you an easier question he was side
sleeper back sleeper stomach slow roll
around you roll around her limbs and
then the four pack specials going to be
perfect for Pierre Garcon I'm talking
about my pillow calm you click on the
radio listeners special tab on my pillow
comm they got a pillow if you're a back
sleeper side sleeper or stomach sleeper
so there's a four pack special scissors
you got to do Pierre call
or go to radio listener special tab at
my pillow comm dropping the promo code
rich and you get up to my premium
pillows and to go anywhere pillows for
40% off oh okay
remember promo code rich all right now
Pierre Garcon you ran what 40-yard dash
you're in if what you run at the Cobb
minor gave me a like three different
times but um four four eight was like
the official official time we were told
for four five is what we were told
that's what we were told
now mine three four four two as well
then I guess we average the mountain it
were four four four five over I ran a
602 this year that's okay you don't have
to say anything that the saying it
actually got worse from last year I had
a 594 last year can we just show Pierre
the video and we'll describe it again
radio audience last year we put together
two 40-yard dashes and back-to-back last
year and Chris law attempted to do 240
drinking his 40 in the amount of time
that I ran my 40-yard dash back-to-back
and he failed miserably now we were
planning on doing again this year until
Taylor luan talked about chugging 40s on
yesterday's show and I decided let's
give Chris law an opportunity to try it
again thanks Taylor
okay now you ready for this pair have
you ever seen anybody trying down to 40
nah go on that not in this okay here we
go
for aerodynamics purposes we put these
in there in the cups here okay here we
go
now I suppose you're - you're - for you
back to back yes okay you've got two
cups of them oh you're not nail this
three three of more you're gonna nail
this all right Mike til to foe you ready
I'm like genuinely nervous oh that's the
way I run my 40 you trust me I feel like
vomiting every time I run my 40 we have
music here we go there you go Chris law
let's put him on the clock with my two
40-yard dashes and back-to-back here we
go go go alright he step out the down oh
he's going to do this
he's done with one glass here I go with
my other one
[Applause]
oh no it's okay we'll go back to back to
back
three guys all right he tapped out
feeling you know so we're done sure okay
that's enough put the glass down put it
down
just hambre are you all right Chris you
tapped out oh wow you go just sit down
sit down
no you guys stand up oh we end up pretty
pleased there did it as well arms up
careful let the air come I cut the mic
here you have any trash talk for this no
no I just gonna separate enough it is
really underwhelming I'm sorry no it's
alright you know what enough you didn't
you didn't have a base you didn't get it
done this year next year there's always
next year Chris law you need training
he's got I don't even know Chris law is
anymore I don't know him he's a mother
at his camp fatherhood has changed him
father understand all right why don't
you say this is really disappointing I
had a lot of people counting on me too
yeah yeah
I'm sorry I often take cash of all it's
really disappointed Pierre yes go back
and tell the stories of you saw B or two
law nothing
you'll tell that gig oh yeah 20:18 will
be my ear attaboy just like the 49ers
yes thanks for coming on Pierre you come
back any time when you're in Los Angeles
oh good enjoy the weekend everybody we
will see you on Monday and I guess again
will have blood me of NBA playoffs
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show lap follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show